in the last video we saw a potential
mechanism where if we reacted hydrogen
bromide with this alkene right over here
that we can essentially add we had the
addition of this of this halide to what
it was started as an alkene and then it
ended up it ended up as two
bromopentane as an alkane but when we
did that we made a i guess you could
call it a somewhat arbitrary decision or
i didn't explain why we made the
decision we said look this hydrogen is
going to be partially positive because
this guy is so electronegative and maybe
when it's partially positive it'll be
attracted maybe it'll just bump in just
the right way into one of these carbons
it'll maybe swipe its electron we
somewhat arbitrarily in the last video
decided that it would swipe this guy's
electron but you could just as easily
imagine a world where it swipes an
electron from this guy so let's draw a
mechanism for that and just think about
which one is more likely to actually
happen so what happens so
once again this guy let me draw all of
his valence electrons so there's the
bromine
one two three four five six seven
valence electrons you have the hydrogen
i'll do it the same color
the hydrogen has its electron right
there this is partially positive and
this is partially negative the hydrogen
might want to swap one might want to
swipe one of these electrons away let's
do it from this guy right here let's do
it from
let's do it from this guy so he has
he has this electron right over here so
the other side of that bond it goes to
the hydrogen when the hydrogen goes near
it or maybe it's attracted to it and
when it goes to the hydrogen then the
hydrogen lets go of the electron that
the bromine wanted all along because
it's so electronegative
so then that electron
goes to the bromine so after we do that
what will it look like
what will be the next step in our
reaction and it will look fundamentally
different than this right over here so
now what happens
now what happens so we have a carbon
bonded to two hydrogens
two hydrogens and only has a single bond
to the other carbon just bonded to
the original hydrogen right over there
the rest let me write my hydrogens a
little bit actually let me write this
whole thing a little bit neater
so you have your carbon bonded to a
hydrogen
and another hydrogen and now it only has
a single bond to this carbon right here
which is bonded to a hydrogen and then
the rest of the chain
let me just draw the rest of the chain
right here
and now this electron went to the
hydrogen the other electron that it was
paired with is still with this carbon so
now this carbon is now bonded to that
hydrogen over there so this blue
electron is now with the hydrogen so let
me draw so the blue electron that was
here is now gone over to the
orange hydrogen has now gone over let me
draw a little bit neater than that has
now gone over to this hydrogen right
over there
and then the hydrogen lost its electron
to the bromine so the bromine originally
had seven valence electrons one two
three four five six seven and then it
nabbed an extra electron from the
hydrogen so now it will have a negative
charge it is a negative ion it's bromide
it's a bromide anion i guess you could
call it and since this guy lost an
electron he had four valence electrons
lost one to the hydrogen he is now he
now has a positive charge he's a
carbo-cation
he's a carbo-cation and then from here
so notice the difference before this guy
lost the electron and so the hydrogen
bonded to this carbon in this situation
this guy lost the electron so the
hydrogen bonded to the other carbon and
so you can imagine from here something
very similar happens is what happened in
the first video but now it happens to
this carbon right over there
so let's do that this carbon is positive
the brom the bromide ion is obviously
negative so maybe he'll want to swipe
his electron away so this electron
then goes
to the carbo cation and then it will
form a bond it will form a bond this
green one will go to the carbohydrate
and then this purple one still stays
with the bromine and so they'll have a
bond they're paired up you can imagine
it so then we're left with we have a
carbon
we have our original hydrogens
we have this carbon that hydrogen the
rest of the chain
the rest of the chain ch2ch
and then you have this hydrogen right
here that it bonded to that was kind of
our first step
and now the bromine has bonded to this
carbon right over here
the bromine has bonded over to that
carbon right over there and we're done
this is another this is another possible
mechanism this one we ended up with two
bromopentane right because it's on the
number two carbon here we have one
bromopentane one two three four five
still five carbons it's just the bromine
is attached to the one carbon here
attached to the two carbon here so we
now need to think about because you know
on a first cut these both seem like
reasonable mechanisms but if you did it
experimentally if you do it did
experimentally you would see that this
is the one that you would really observe
i haven't actually i actually haven't
done this exact experiment so i don't
know the proportions but you're going to
observe this one disproportionately the
great majority of of the products that
you see are going to be this one not
that one and so the question is well you
know they both seem like reasonable
things to do up here why is this one so
much more likely to happen than that one
it all comes from something called
markovnikov's rule
markovnikov's rule mar
rule and there's a couple of ways to
think about it and when markovnikov
thought it up or he observed it it
seemed to work they weren't 100 sure
about why it worked we can even think a
little bit about why it worked so
markovnikov's rule a couple ways you can
think about it you could think of it as
the thing that already has more
hydrogens is more likely to get more
hydrogens so that's what happened here
this thing had more hydrogens on it than
this then the right carbon right here
this right carbon had a hydrogen but it
had some other i guess you'd call it an
alkyl group attached to it and so the
thing that had more hydrogens ended up
with the hydrogen and then the thing
that had more groups
this character right here had more
groups right he had one group over here
this carbon over here had no groups he
ended up with the bromine so the thing
that has more hydrogens ends up with
more hydrogens the thing that ends up
that has more groups ends up with more
groups so i guess you kind of go more in
the direction that you were going in but
that still is just you know a rule so
you know why does that make sense it all
makes sense
or it starts to make sense when you
think about that in both mechanisms we
had to have a carbocation
right we talked about in the last video
carbo
cation we had a carbocation right over
there this is the left carbon being a
carbocation this is the right carbon
being a carbocation and markovnikov's
rule is all all comes from which carbo
cation is more stable which one has a
lower energy level
and it turns out that the carbocation
that is bonded to more i guess electron
rich electron rich
molecules or atoms is going to be more
stable you can imagine that it has more
things that look it's positive but it
has more carbons around it so it can
share some of those electrons you know
the electron clouds will help it out a
little bit to be a little bit more
stable this one right here is only
bonded to one other carbon so not as
much sharing this is bonded to two so in
general so when you're only bonded to
one other when you're only bonded to one
other carbon you're called a primary
carbon
primary carbon and if you're carbocation
this is a primary carbocation right here
this guy is bonded to two carbons so he
would be called a secondary carbon since
it's a carbocation it's a secondary
carbocation so this right here is
secondary
secondary so a secondary carbocation is
more stable than a primary and actually
a tertiary if you had another a carbon
group here or something else that had a
lot of electrons around it that would be
even more stable so ter three bonded to
three things more stable than two things
and when i say two things two things
other than hydrogen and then more stable
than one so the markovnikov's rule all
is a byproduct of the fact that this
carbocation is more stable than this one
over here and that's because it's
secondary versus primary because it's
secondary it can kind of borrow
electrons from some of its friends it
has more neighbors to borrow electrons
than this one and since this is more
stable this is more likely to happen
this this is a more likely
intermediate to have this is a less
likely outcome to have in general and
that's why you're more likely to get to
this left product the 2-bromopentane
than the 1-bromopentane